strange we all right
[Music]
you backyard hey what was that look
forward in time to view alternate
futures to see all the possible outcomes
of the coming conflict how many did you
see
fourteen million six hundred five how
many we win
what I really like the character of
nightmare and the concept that the
nightmare nightmare realm is a dimension
I always thought that was one of the
that's early that's like in the first
strange tale I think that's in the
introductory Epps episode of Doctor
Strange and I always loved that well we
decided not to do that just because
that's a bit of a complex idea to try to
introduce everything that we do
introduced and introduced the idea of
nightmares themselves as being another
dimension
I hope somewhere down the line we get to
explore that except I think that's a
super cool concept hey everybody it's
Charlie British news sites have been
reporting that Doctor Strange 2 is gonna
get started sometime next year so we
need to talk about what's going on the
reason I included that clip is because
the director scott derrickson already
said what he really wants to do for the
sequel so if you're brand new to the
channel there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this you
may remember awhile ago I did a couple
of phase 4 videos about all the movies
that Kevin Feige had confirmed that
they're working on there are actually
several Doctor Strange - was one of
those but at the time when he announced
that they didn't say when they were
gonna be working on it so it could have
been any time in the next couple of
years but most of the new sites that are
talking about this are talking about
Benedict Cumberbatch's supreme paycheck
that he's gonna earn for it which is
about seven and a half million dollars
is what they're expecting as far as we
know it's gonna be all the same people
that worked on the first film same
writer same director which is why the
Scott Derrickson comments are so
important because the nightmare
character The Nightmare Realm is a very
different twist from what we expected
based on that Baron Mordo post-credit
scene from the first film
[Music]
why are you doing this because I see it
long-last what's wrong at the wall
his whole thing about there being too
much magic out there is that he was
taking it from people that he had either
trained or trained with so the idea was
the reckoning that he told dr. strange
that would be coming was him in fact he
was the reckoning but revisiting the
idea of nightmares as the setting for
the Doctor Strange sequel makes so much
more sense after what happened during
infinity war and what's happening during
Avengers 4 so even if they don't let
Scott Derrickson do a legit horror film
in the Marvel Universe imagine Nightmare
on Elm Street dream warriors but with
the Doctor Strange character Doctor
Strange battling the character nightmare
through the nightmares of all the
biggest people on earth like the a-list
Avengers imagine Doctor Strange
traveling through spider-man's
nightmares we've even seen one of Iron
Man's nightmares because that was what
happened at the beginning of age of
Ultron Scarlet Witch gave him that
vision he references it during infinity
war I've been living with this for the
last six years I don't think you quite
understand what's it's know here it's
you who doesn't understand that Thanos
has been inside my head for six years
since he sent an army to New York and
now he's back and I don't know what to
do
so I'm not so sure if it's a better plan
if I don't want to Archer for his but
you saw what they did what they can do
he said a couple other things that he
wants to include in the Doctor Strange
sequel but that might change if he
really does do Nightmare Realm
because Clea for example is something
that he's talked about but she's really
a character that flows from Dormammu so
if you're not gonna do Dormammu then
it's a little bit harder to include her
but you can tease her and then maybe do
her in a third film and even if they
don't go right back to him Dormammu is a
really good candidate for say like a
Phase six overarching villain to replace
something like danos if they're not
gonna use Galactus worth they're not
gonna use some other big cosmic villain
there are a number of like different big
main arcs that they could do we don't
know exactly what that's going to be so
we'll have to wait till after Avengers 4
to start theory crafting about that if
you're not familiar with the nightmare
character just like scott derrickson
said in that clip he's one of the
earliest Doctor Strange villains but
he's sort of a Dormammu type character
that reigns over the dream realm they
call it the Nightmare Realm but he
basically lives in people's dreams and
feeds off their psychic energy generated
by nightmares so the crazier the
nightmares the more powerful he gets so
think about the nightmares after
Avengers infinity war in Avengers for
now we all know that the Avengers are
gonna fix things but the idea is is that
some people in the world's special
people like the a-list Avengers will
remember things even if it's only on a
subconscious level so even if they
stitched together aspects of different
realities or change the timeline so that
the snap sure never happened they'll
still be some people that come out of
Avengers for remembering everything that
happened all the craziness imagine those
nightmares
supercharging the character nightmares
so that he becomes so powerful he
threatens the waking realm so that
eventually Doctor Strange has to go
confront him like you see people walking
around near Bleecker Street just seeming
like complete zombies in the waking
hours of the day and Doctor Strange is
like oh this isn't good so he has to go
into their dreams so even though I'm not
expecting it to be a big huge Avengers
crossover you can still have him
traveling through the Avengers
nightmares which is like just a really
fun way to have a couple of funny
moments but also still do it as a
straight-up horror film like Spider Man
another New York based character imagine
the nightmares that Spider Man has after
dying and coming back to life
start I don't feel so good
you're right he becomes a little bit of
an Iron Man analogue after that first
Avengers film like when we picked up an
Iron Man 3 and he was just living with
this crazy PTSD imagine Spider Man and
all the other Avengers that survived
having a version of that and having to
deal with that the first time that they
pick up and whatever movies they pop up
and like Spider Man far from home
even if they don't focus on that in that
movie they'll probably have to deal with
it at some point Doctor Strange
traveling through their dreams dream
doctor is the perfect way to reference
some of that stuff if you're asking
about Mephisto Scarlet Witch the other
magic based x-men characters because of
this Disney deal I think a lot of that
just depends on how self-contained that
they want this movie to be I'm not
expecting a whole bunch of other
Avengers characters to pop up in this
nor x-men because if they're really
gonna be starting next year that's
really quick the Disney deal won't quite
be done yet and if they do include
Scarlet Witch it's probably only gonna
be a cameo I'm really hoping that they
use her to set up the idea of Chaos
magic so that they can do something with
that during phase 4 because she's a huge
female character she's one of the most
powerful people that they have on the
Avengers if they're doing this big thing
in the next couple of years where they
try to include all the most badass big
powerful female characters he would be
really weird for them to make her ride
the bench so I feel like Scarlet Witch
will return during phase four but we
don't know exactly how they plan to use
her yet because currently snap sure
status pending so she might go on a bit
of a vacation with vision after Avengers
4 if they bring both of those characters
back but just expect marble to do a big
comic-con panel next summer where they
announce exactly what the schedule is
going to be for the next like three to
four years let me know in the comments
though what do you want them to do with
the Doctor Strange sequel if they do
nightmare around which other characters
do you want to see pop up in that
remember it's probably not gonna be a
giant Avengers crossover because they
don't want to spend a billion dollars on
it but I wouldn't be surprised if we see
a couple of the characters pop up really
hoping for a minor spider-man cameo just
because they are in New York Bros
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video Louis B
Avalos please email me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact
details there's a new daredevil season 3
preview I'll post later tonight but
click here to learn all about that Iron
Man Illuminati Easter egg and click
here for that Avengers 4 title teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]